so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody happy friday
welcome welcome to evil dead the game
i'm john xepke video producer here at
gamespot and i'm joined by the lovely
banjanka as always ben
hello
how's it going give me your best evil
dead uh quote what's your favorite
uh hail to the king baby excellent
shop smart shop as smart
[Laughter]
this is my boomstick
please enjoy keep them coming uh all
right everybody happy friday
we're playing evil dead the game here
i'm very excited about this because not
only do i love people dead but i
i am a big fan of these kinds of like
let's take an old horror franchise and
turn it into like an asymmetrical
multiplayer thing
[Music]
it's good
[ __ ] i think this may be my favorite
combination
like my favorite setup for one of them
too
because it takes like the
the way that you
you do like uh was it resident evil
reverse
uh like kind of orchestrating and
dropping bad guys all over the place for
the human players to deal with yeah
um and you actually get to fight stuff
as the survivors which i really enjoy
so i'm i'm jazzed up on it
as it were
excellent
but uh i i don't think i've gotten
uh an invite for me yet yeah i'm
currently
figuring that out uh i've hit the button
i've received an invite i've excellent
i've joined you've joined oh work
fantastic
you'd love to see it love to see it all
right so yeah i think we're going to
start here with
uh
us and two random people versus a.i
uh to get our c legs in here
um yeah then once we feel comfortable
we'll switch to doing like a proper
versus
um
with other players because yeah this
game is a little complicated i did the
tutorial and kind of understand the
basics but
definitely need to do a little more here
uh yes we're all annie um
i'm probably just gonna go with cheryl
right off the bat
uh because she is
my favorite healer okay all right um
we got three different ashes to play
which is great okay so if you're gonna
be a healer
uh
someone's kelly so it's support
we already got a hunter so
i don't know
leader maybe
should i be should i be annie
you go for it
or should i be i should probably be a
ash see if we don't have an ash we
should have an ass we should have an ash
all right i'll be i'll be another
warrior man
i'm the guy you can never go wrong with
more uh smacking things around all right
let's do it
this is cross play it is cross play you
can totally play with people online we
are playing against we're on pc we're
playing with two people on playstation
when i played earlier i was playing with
xbox people
and um obviously i don't want to jinx it
because
the game's been out for like what only a
few hours now but
so far
the servers have been
pretty good i have not run into any
connection issues i have gotten into
matches very quickly
so uh
definitely a win uh as far as
it's not a uh professor raymond
department of ancient history uh
what was it um
fry the 13th
yeah so it's four players uh
i know the whole thing is you want to at
least stick in pairs because if you're
by yourself you'll like your fear meter
will increase
yeah and then you gotta have matches to
light fires is that you with that axe
there
with this this cool sledge hammer you
better
grab that
oh the other cool thing that i like too
is uh like your light is more of a
function than just being a light yeah it
actually reveals stuff yeah it finds
finds hidden things when you shine it on
them and that's kind of neat
a meat cleaver huh
it does seem to have a i know it has
like a percentage and
yeah
uh that's a good question i don't think
i've gotten far enough to know because i
cuz i ran out of it i like left it on in
a match and then it was at zero and i it
just i couldn't use my flashlight
anymore i was like oh
it seems like a problem anyway let's do
it this way right
now yeah so the map
which is cool
there's a lot here
um guys that's a pretty beefy map
oh this is one of the altars that you
use to bring someone back i think if
they die oh good good
just trying to try to still find out
exactly what everything is on the map oh
yeah
i did the tutorial and i did one match
where we got um
we found all the pieces of the map okay
so the objectives of this game is you
have to find all three pieces of the map
the map will tell you where
uh the pages of the necronomicon are as
well as the dagger
you need to go then collect those
you then need to defeat the um
demons that are guarding the
necronomicon and then you need to
collect i'm supposed to use that
we gotta we gotta
kick him out of here
hello is the game available now if not
one will be released it is available now
i believe it costs 40 bucks and
it is a
epics
game store exclusive on pc which
i don't love that
um
but it's also the lawn xbox
uh playstation
let's get that finisher
the finishers in this game are
very good
so we've kind of abandoned our friends
but
well as long as they're together i i
definitely feel like you want to split
up between
you just don't want to be by yourself
right yeah yeah
um maybe let's go check out uh
dead end
sounds like a plan to me
just gonna say we got a car that we can
we can use
oh
double barrel
hell yeah well that's signature that's
that just makes sense all right
hop on in all right i'm driving um
yeah you know it's good when you're
driving with the mouse and keyboard
should we check out this building what
do you think
yeah i'm down to basically just look at
anything at this point
also real talk i kind of just like
fighting things
what's wrong with the sound is the sound
oh hold on let me uh
i might be getting uh possessed here in
a second if i don't
light a fire or something i think that's
what i want to do
sorry if we're getting double sound
you might be hearing a little sound
oh no
my uh
my setup is not the best when it comes
to like
let's sit under this light for a bit
it's not good audio is weird man
dude i've been having weird um
discord issues with audio where is it i
guess we could try to try to figure out
is is it my mic that's messed up or is
it both mics that are messed up that's a
good question
because that'll help us figure out how
we can we can get it sorted
strange
it's not you i'll tell you right now if
it's if it's happening it's happening on
my end because you sound perfect to me
so it might be something coming through
the stream stuff then
that's what i'm thinking i was having so
i had this weird issue earlier with obs
where
the game audio sounded bad and then i
just reset obs and it sounds fine
so it's possible it's just my obs
i might be
[Music]
so it doesn't look like it's coming
through
mine
right now at least looking at discord
so no funny audio cable things
do funny audio people think
yeah give me like a sec story
i'm gonna keep doing my best to protect
you be here
try fixing something
all right ben
yes
uh let's see if that works
all right cool cool
all right chat tell me if that improved
the audio for you guys at all
it was a big guy
so yeah we're encountering some
some trouble here
uh
we should keep moving right
yeah we should we should probably get
out here
our teammates are probably what are you
guys doing
sounds like a mic is registering
weird
i don't know how that that's happening
people say it's better now okay so i
know it's good um basically the issue
was i
like my monitor audit i had to like set
it so i could monitor the game audio so
i could hear it
and that was causing like root issues so
it's been fixed now um i just can't hear
the game at all which um
that'll be interesting but i'd rather
have the um
uh the viewers obviously have like the
superior
yeah i'll just tell you whenever ash has
a one-liner okay thank you i appreciate
that yeah
so uh yeah i might be missing out on
some some audio cues but it's fine
we're here we're doing it
oh my god ben these guys just do not
stop
it's true uh
i'm gonna say we should definitely leave
yeah i agree um should we get back in
the car
i think our car is still all right
good good to hear that i'm i'm set now
my my audio is all good
yeah i gotta sort that out
it's always fun uh
your audio is is is wild
like it's it's not an easy thing to to
get set up
get him
okay okay so we should go
let me go to like the
uh heads up look at this
this place
that's our car gone
this is still over here oh no it's gone
you're right never mind
damn all right um
yeah let's just head this way
let's go to where they've got it marked
a bit
i don't know how that's possible
i just have it playing straight through
i thought i'm not that audible
people saying i'm fine people saying i'm
not fine we're we're all over the place
maybe me i need to speak up
that guy doesn't need to speak i'm a bit
low okay yeah hold on let me let me
boost my uh
my game a little bit then if that's the
case
oh the guy was yelling for you he's like
no ash we need to save you
yeah all right i'm gonna boost that up
by like
three
months
all right i've boosted myself a little
bit
there it is that
you're you're not too quiet the other
guy is just too loud
which is something i've heard before
no
i don't i don't agree with that ben
because uh i definitely
have a i don't know if it's just
something about my voice or what but
anytime i ever do any sort of uh
like audio thing like a live stream or a
podcast with people i always have to
boost myself way more than everyone else
regardless of the setup so i think i
just i talked about it oh that tree
attacked me what the [ __ ]
yeah do they got flipping the the angry
trees
yo i don't know i don't
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
call this just yet but i don't know if
we're gonna actually make it
probably not this time around where are
you
uh we've moved up to harry's house
the we literally weren't here we dropped
in
someone who's done this who is the other
guy uh so i'm john luke
this is my gameplay you're seeing the
other guy that is ben janka
we work for gamespots.com we do
doing various all sorts of
fun things that you guys get to see
including this live stream
uh where we're checking out
the new released evil dead game
struggling along trying to find these uh
these map pieces
who jon snow knows
it is groovy
all right harry's house here
here uh you're you're right there i'm
gonna i'll drop some healing on you
i appreciate that because uh
healing is a good thing for all of us
i'm gonna use my melee here
so we haven't really like
properly
done a thing yeah
uh
no we already have looked through this
house [ __ ]
yeah we need to
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to mark
something
here ben get in this car
get in this car
mom away all right we're going
it's it's just us we're leaving them
we're leaving them
let's check out uh
the auto zone
all right
it's over here
yeah lovely
i've learned how to work the map so i
can at least mark things
uh
is kevin do you think you should buy the
game is it worth it to buyers too soon
to predict uh i like it a lot uh
i'm i'm enjoying myself
i guess if if
you like asymmetrical multiplayer games
you've got some good friends to kind of
jump in with
uh you'd probably have a good time with
it especially if you like evil dead like
i'd say that's a gimme oh yeah i was
gonna say it really depends on like yeah
yeah do you have a bunch of friends do
you like these kinds of games in general
medieval dead fan
um personally i've barely played enough
to really pass any sort of like
uh judgment but so far it seems like a
pretty good version of you know this
kind of game
and it's got all the evil dead [ __ ] in
it so uh so far
pretty positive on it
um
but i think the big thing for me is
always like oh like you know is it is it
fun
after you know x amount of hours and x
amount of uh
uh runs
yeah i'm uh i'm also really curious what
they're gonna do like
like post launched too because i don't
think i've heard anything about that
sure i mean the thing is they've kind of
like included pretty much
all the major stuff you'd want
so
um
i
like all the characters that kind of
represented all the movies are
represented i guess except for the evil
dead uh reboot or
reimagining that they did yeah they
could get that maybe more
more map things just to just mix it up
yo i actually like that that version of
uh evil dead i do too it was it was
really good it's a very different movie
um but that's what i think makes it kind
of fun
and um
it that last like 30 minutes
goes so good off the rails in a way that
i really enjoyed
i found a saw gun and it's good okay uh
oh though
we uh okay we got ap some map
so they've got something going on over
there maybe we should go join them uh i
was gonna say we should go check out the
gas and go i think i'm dying to do that
yeah this area seems like a terrorism
uh how do the different classes work
so i think it's based on like their
abilities and some other stats right
yeah they're you basically get like a
special like hero ability
so since i'm i'm i'm a support i get to
just drop a healing field on the ground
yeah
i'm a hunter like
weapon focus so uh my mine kind of just
gives me like some damage boost and
makes me a little more resistant for
like a hot minute yeah yours just like
buffs you up yeah essentially
speaking of healing though i'm gonna
drop this because i need it thank you
all right let's uh let's get out of here
um
i do like how like
compared to say um
dead by daylight or
friday the 13th because this is evil
dead it's way more
kind of combat focused uh there's a lot
more like the things so eyes are
actually just like fighting all the time
for for me a big thing that
like i like dead by daylight enough and
i love that they've managed to like grab
all those licenses it's really neat
uh but i wish that you could do more to
fight back in that game
uh which is why i really enjoy this kind
of take on it where i'm able to fight
stuff
i agree um i like that in friday the
13th a lot too
yeah i'm gonna be honest i
liked friday the 13th more than evil day
uh not evil dead then um dead by
daylight
yeah i i do too uh and i think it's that
that little bit of being able to fight
that that did it for me like yeah
and you've also got a cool bunch of cool
like oh if you're the first person out
and they call the police you get to come
back as the police officer oh yeah or
tommy jarvis or yeah
yeah like cool little things to keep you
playing even though you may have like no
one wants to be the first one out in a
game like this that's what's real boring
but it gives you a reason to stick
around i'm i'm real bummed what happened
to that game friday the 13th
uh me too you deserved better especially
since they were about to take us to
space with it i know we missed we didn't
get it
ugh what a bummer
um
though they're making um
aren't they making the texas chainsaw
game
think so
uh
i want to say the texas chainsaw game is
being made by them which if so good for
them
uh because that probably will be pretty
fun too
yeah
um
oh my god these guys do not stop coming
yeah i don't know if there's anything
here we probably should just go in and
join them i'm thinking you think so so
do you know if the map pieces are kind
of like near each other is that how that
works i think so
or at least every other time i've i've
seen it they are okay we could do that
then but that's like back where we were
like they're just kind of in that area
yeah and they would have found another
one by now i think let's check the
junkyard oh you're about to die i should
have dropped a healing for us
also my my character's stressing i'm
going the wrong way yours is the blue
marker right
yeah mine's the blue marker
homies what's up what's up man happy
friday
how's it going
hanging out
go this way
yo keyboard driving though
oh my goodness
let's not talk about
anything i'm just gonna drop healing
back here by the car
uh the guy said something about going to
the pond
oh okay
uh i'm gonna go light up these matches
so i don't lose my mind and hurt you
if i can get over there
oh
you're also in the same boat
yeah
just need some light you know
okay so we're in the
uh
yeah do you want to just keep like
running towards the junkyard area
uh
i say we meet him at the pond because
that's what they were talking about
that's where they're going okay yeah we
could do that
um
here come over come over by this fire
real quick
oh it does say at the top right there's
a map piece near the pond
oh okay
cool maybe i should pay attention to the
ui
yes
[Laughter]
it's it's a learning experience still
it also doesn't help that i don't have
audio
yeah you are playing at a bit of a
disadvantage
all right let's uh
let me start running that way yeah
you have any uh any cola coal to drink
yeah there you go unfortunately but i
did boost myself so at least i got that
there's a car up here too
that we won't flip over and i keep
saying we
to make myself feel a bit better about
it
are you guys playing on max settings uh
i am actually playing on like the second
highest settings i did set it to max and
there's no reason my computer shouldn't
be able to run it on max i have a
3080 ti in here but um it was kind of
stuttering a little bit um so i
put it back to uh
to just like high so that um i would i'd
get a smoother frame rate
okay
this time for real
let's go to the pond oh wait oh they got
the pawn piece so uh royal oak cemetery
let's go there which we were at before
yeah which is still over this way yeah
yeah yeah you're on the right path
uh
there are like single-player campaign
missions right kind of
yeah like like missions inspired by the
films and moments from the films
it's not like a full-on campaign
yeah just kind of little mini bits i
haven't tried them yet so i can't
comment on their quality but i know that
you unlock you'll unlock like characters
and and stuff for doing that yeah um
definitely gonna check those out because
i think you can get
ash from the
evil dead tv show
and stuff like that
i'm gonna go light this fire over here
because i am again
super scared
or i'm not going to light it
the heroic survivors have gathered the
fire i can maybe light it
yeah yeah
and i'll drop healing for us
excellent
oh look it's just all coming together oh
that's weird did it not maybe i didn't
hold it long enough
oh okay
you have to hold it a little bit longer
than uh it claims you do so keep holding
it until you've like fully lit it
sick yeah let's regenerate ourselves and
then um
and they've got a car here for us cool
we should definitely like hard here for
us i mean
i think they took our car oh that's okay
and they're driving away with it all
right well let's just follow them then
because we need to get to
we should all be together for
yeah for these things for these things
all right i'm just gonna start running
sounds like a plan i'm gonna
i guess loot this house on my way
through
uh
uh
uh
i just died are you watching that too oh
no
i can't play it oh so someone was
watching evil dead too just to
just to do it heck yeah dude
always a good time to watch evil dead
too
it's true
oh my goodness
so i don't know how true this was but uh
apparently there were talks that um
the they were going to like
uh
make a sequel to that evil dead reboot
but it was going to be a crossover
between both evil dead universes
where somehow like
one of either the either the main girl
from that movie or ash was gonna like
come through like some sort of
dimensional portal and then they were
gonna have to work together as like
the protagonist
and i thought that was a cool idea and
i'm sad that that never happened
uh i like the sound of that and i wish
it happened too
we did get the evil dead tv show which i
admittedly have only seen the first
episode
uh yeah i don't think i've seen too much
of it myself too but i think it went for
like two three seasons though right
yeah
i should probably i should probably
check more of that out
oh they're flipping bad dudes are right
here oh that's the dudes
all right well uh
we gotta we gotta do all the page stuff
first yeah but
yikes
drop some healing
all right let's get this
so we get to do some cool like point
defense here
sarah in the chat big fan of uh
the ash vs evil dead show
they said it's incredible so all right
cool
it is my my kind of blind zone in terms
of like the franchise and i should
probably fix that right right
yeah it's one of those things that like
i feel like it never got like
big mainstream attention but uh
the people who like it apparently say
it's really good so i feel like i should
check it out
it's also one of those shows where i
feel like
anyone who gave it the time to watch it
and says it's good probably you you'd
definitely trust them
oh sure
like i feel like it's a it's the kind of
thing that not a lot of people go out of
the way like i'm gonna go off on a limb
and watch this evil dead tv series
because
yeah
i mean
from what i remember when at least when
it first aired it wasn't on like a
streaming service it was like
it was like showtime or something like
that um
don't quote me on that the point is that
it wasn't like easily accessible you had
to go out of your way to watch it like
you said yeah
i'm gonna drop some more healing here
when i can
oh my god if i if i don't die first
you are in possession of the candarian
dagger oh hey there's a supply crate
i'm going to do it because it's just an
upgraded version what i have
weird
i'm also going to level my
self up
oh yeah because i have not gotten
anything to heal myself let's boost that
health um okay we should to the next
area
stars thank you cat we don't have time
got three minutes to do this before that
tv show is on
uh yeah who has stars
you know like
what are your thoughts in the game so
far
uh are you enjoying it
so far yeah it's cool
i think the big thing will be like how
much um
variety does it feel like there is uh or
variation in between matches
you have awakened the lost pages of the
necronomicon
i don't know i don't if we're gonna have
enough time to do it
yeah we wasted too much time
it's it's okay so it's a learning
experience we're still going to get xp
for like oh sure doing stuff
i had a good time precious memories i'll
never forget
oh this guy's so close yeah there we go
i'm gonna drop some healing again
it's on hulu okay so now the show's on
hulu
okay
i got hulu i should check it out
yeah i'm down
maybe i'll make that a part of my um
like october or month
oh it'd be perfect also the shoe is
going by too fast and that's coming up
way too soon
yeah it's already made dude
uh
it's a heck of a thing i i don't like it
the the slow march of time
uh
turns out it's actually not that slow
it's going way too fast please please
slow down
oh no
yeah we're gonna get this page unless it
it doesn't it won't give us like more
time will it
i don't think so
whoa also two people just went down
it's on netflix as well
uh oh hell yeah
people are saying okay cool cool
oh you got him
someone got him
i'm getting shocked again i'm gonna put
down more health
okay we did it hey no the timer went
away
we're good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah perfect
overtime baby let's go
uh
there's a shotgun there for you
there we go okay yeah a little finicky
sometimes it doesn't want to
oh he's possessed possessed
he's gonna knock him around a bit
get him all right he's good he's good
he's good okay
all right we just gotta go get those
guys now
i'm gonna go by this campfire i think
we're about to light
oh sure
yeah let me let me light that up
i decided to camp or whatever this is
there we go nice
yeah let's just uh get everyone's fear
down
and then
let's get in there
oh they're going in oh they're just
going for it all right we should go then
sounds like a plan uh
so can anyone do the whole dagger thing
or does like one person have to do that
i think we all do it okay yeah the
ghostbusters
all right one segment down
punch dudes out ah jump scared though
oh yeah yeah are you getting
possessed uh not not even possessed just
they did a jump scare on me and i didn't
wasn't prepared for it
yeah that happened to me earlier
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
bring around the just focus it
nice
all right one more one more
i'm going to put down some health
joe are we are we saving the day are we
doing it i think we're saving the day oh
heck yeah all right
now we gotta just uh protect the book
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
god show up scared again stop it
get out of here
there are so many dudes
so i'm gonna light this fire back here
just in case we need it oh no someone
died
i don't like it
oh my god i died
you died i got like one i got like one
shot
oh [ __ ]
that's uh
there's only have a minute though you
got this
are we just holding it off for a minute
is that the idea i think it's just for a
minute that you gotta hold it off
okay uh is there friendly fire i
i don't think so maybe i'm like a higher
difficulty yeah it doesn't seem like oh
it's just you oh no
oh i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
make this
let's see though
oh there are chainsaws there are
multiple chainsaws yes there are
chainsaws
oh he's
he's cheering on
no
dang
that was close though
yeah yeah
man
okay
it'd be like that sometimes you know
yeah
do you want to do another one against ai
or do we want to go uh against real
people
uh i'm down for either or
living
i want to try real people i'm sure
that'll go
even better
oh yeah
let's see if it got any uh
because there are also skill trees for
all the characters that's true why don't
we look at that uh see if i can
get some upgrades
yeah
so i realized i should be recording this
so that
i got hot gameplay here um
let's see i played warrior ash so
yeah look at this i do like all this
part they they drew it's really good
yeah i like like got i got costumes
hello all right last hit of your combo
causes increased damage yeah that's good
let's get that
all right that's it i had only the one
skill point
uh i think they give you one skill point
for every person oh yeah
uh so i'm just frantically running
through
and applying that
uh to everyone right now
you know that's probably a good idea
galley at night
oh
i have the s smart uniform i gotta wear
that
oh heck yeah
oh
a sick explorer outfit we're dressed up
like indiana jones now
heck yeah yeah why don't i go through
each character and just quickly cash in
that that one skill point
and then also look at their outfits oh
yeah yeah we'll explore outfit that's
cool
when will your review for the game be
out uh it's currently being worked on
but the game just came out and
uh obviously this game is multiplayer
focused so it's a lot of it's like
testing it
uh in a live environment so i would say
don't expect
any reviews until like early next week
uh at the the soonest
but it's on the way it's on the way it
is being worked on
college outfit
sure
okay
changes
all right we got evil dead two ash
interesting i really love all the people
whose upgrades are just
your drink does more health
all the demons got points too i don't
need to worry about that so much though
yeah i don't i think we're gonna do
much demon stuff
at the moment
kelly doesn't have an alternate outfit
i'll just quickly do these last two and
then we'll hop back in another game
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i'm sure people are very excited to
see us go through all these others
because through all these venues
sorry guys lovely lovely gameplay
this is this is to make the gameplay
better that extra range on the guns
yeah
oh
i don't like that outfit that's nice
i'm curious at least with the demons oh
they got a lot of skill trees wow
yeah they've actually got a choice
looking demon that is
uh can i show that on a stream jesus
you wonder sometimes but i think you're
okay all right
wow
there's a lot of the demons that i
definitely
too hot for twitch
all cool kids do demon stuff
it's true
i love that they have the army of
darkness demons oh that's so cool
oh and they have all the dumb like like
jokes like one of the one of the
abilities is like
playing the flute or something
yeah
like it's that
there's so much just good evil dead
nonsense in this game that
it it makes me really happy just to see
it
hey steve welcome what'd you miss uh
we've only played one game and we uh we
made it all the way to the end
like the last 30 seconds and and and
couldn't quite make it but
you're just in time for our next one but
this time we'll have talents and
costumes so we're sure to win all right
ben i'm inviting you
i'm on the way
[Music]
jonathan evans before you buy guys
already did a review wow
that's very quick that's very quick
less than 12 hours yeah
i mean
uh
that's that's uh before you buy that's
jake paul dino right
believe something uh i like jack baldy
you know he's cool dude um you gotta
quit watching can't wait till you get
home i understand but i'm so glad that
you came by
all right man it's
it's a good time
it is a good time and i'm very excited
to play more of this with people over
the weekend
yeah
i feel like there's just like so much
stuff to kind of
kind of
learn about oh everyone's got the
flipping idiot and jones off what's
going on
uh
let's see
who's everyone picking this thing took
my parents
i want payback oh
let's see we got a support ash
uh sporadic heals by begetting
kelly as a hunter so i can go warrior if
you want to stick with support i could i
could stick with uh with ash yeah
i'll do that i'll level them up
i like the idea of uh
of a healing while i'm beating things
down
he also said the good bad i'm the guy
with the gun line when i picked him so i
had to do it
your favorite thing so far just the evil
dead like
just seeing evil dead stuff yeah
probably is my favorite bit
but i also like uh i like that there's a
lot of combat and a lot of fighting
right like
i like that it's not just grab a
flashlight and run around not not
sliding to the end by daylight at all i
enjoy playing it but
i like hiding in stuff as much as the
next guy but i like fighting maybe just
a little bit more the following steps to
be taken in order to start with the
mayor's house here deviate from them at
your own hazards or not mayor misery
manor that's what it is
okay i'm gonna
sometimes my uh my collect button
doesn't work that's a little finicky
i'll be there ben
yeah okay sounded like you cut out for a
sec
says this is me me coughing i'm just
dying it's whatever you're good you're
good
um should i get this boom stick or just
keep this revolver
on he holds it with one hand too oh
that's so good
it's that type of stuff you know
oh i love it
ah
uh this or friday the 13th um
i need to play more time with it to
really decide but um
i don't know they're kind of going for
two different things a little bit in
some ways like you know because this is
more combat focused
uh where the survivors are definitely um
you know more about just trying to hide
in that game so kind of kind of going
for different different flavor
yeah i like
i like that friend of the 13th game
quite a bit i like friday the 13th a lot
and i'm still heartbroken that it's
like not going anywhere yeah it's pretty
much gone it's pretty much dead at this
point but like i said i'm pretty sure
that team is working on the um
texas chainsaw game so i hope that
that uh
that works out for them
yeah i know i'll be i'll be playing it
oh lever action rifle perfect um i
should get with you guys because i'm by
myself and that cannot be good for my
stamina
oh
i also got a jump scare
i wonder why that happens is that just
random or can like the
is that a thing the
oh the what what part the the jump scare
that happens
oh yeah you can you actually place them
oh nice okay uh you can also booby trap
uh
boxes and stuff
oh
so like you can put uh like
uh the the mini ashes in there or like
uh
like a hand yeah and it jumps out and
like
like flicks you off and everything
it's really good
uh oh we got one michael heim here in
the chat what up michael
oh i know that guy
fan bites own michael hym
oh i should get out the car
oh uh first piece uh
the nobi cabin
so oh i'm possessed
yeah you are flipping get out of here
what are you hitting me with i have a
spear
oh no not my boomstick
there we go
damn that sucks though because you
just
your allies have to just take a huge
chunk of your health
uh that's that's the that's the
dangerous game you know
uh yeah we we should definitely be over
by the cabin
yeah oh this is a different map too
okay well that answers my question if
there were multiple maps
um yeah should we should we drive so i'm
gonna i'm gonna mark it
and we can we can
i don't wanna say we should abandon our
friend
we probably should abandon our friend
okay oh the chainsaw in here oh well no
get that
i can't use it oh can i use it i can use
it
oh baby let's see it's specific to the
ashes that have lost their hands
now we're talking
all right let's go
i should probably not drive i only have
one uh one hand
the other hand that's fair
i'll drive it
uh navigate me here uh okay we're
heading to the cabin so i'm gonna turn
around and go this way um yep you're
going right
um
let's see
maybe take a right up here
yeah okay
take it right up here
this car is going slow keep going
you know keep following this road here
for a little bit
oh yeah we're almost there heck yeah
and there you go yeah perfect
uh i do like how i i think it benefits
to to have a person navigate
on top of like 100 percent
we've got a flipping teamwork going on
in the car
yo all right so we're at the cabin the
cabin
the captain
and i'm gonna change all the [ __ ] out of
this guy yeah
this game's all right
found the piece of the map
the survivors have acquired the first
piece of woman
all these shocking guys are a lot
that's like that's the proper enemy i'm
sure you're like a person
oh what
oh hello oh what no no did we get
disconnected oh no what's going on
oh the oh they quit or they got
disconnected oh i think they quit or got
disconnected yeah that's oh i mean we
won i mean i don't want to win this way
oh that's a little bit of a bummer
man i like just got the chainsaw uh
arm two
i feel really good about it
oh cool cool we'll get you another
chainsaw
let's just get in there and keep going
is this gta 6 good question
i mean not quite uh if you were to tell
me that bruce campbell
was oh my god protagonist of gta 6 i'd
be pretty
if we play as bruce campbell gta 6 yeah
oh
hey remember when it was like
pretty much uh like 95 confirmed that
ash was supposed to show up in mortal
kombat 11 and then he didn't
yeah and then something happened what
happened there i want to know
like
the tease was there
the stuff made sense it was just
some day someone's gonna get the
interview for that and figure out why
they had to backtrack yeah
because
you don't rev a chainsaw and have it not
be ash or the doom slayer we got neither
that's the thing it wasn't even like oh
it was actually this it was just it
seemed like it was evil dead like no
there was nothing that chainsaw rev led
to nothing
yeah very strange
mk11 is still pretty good but man it
could have been so much better yeah
i'm also very much of the opinion that
um
as cool as it is that you get these
these fun little like you know monster
kind of movie cameos in
mortal kombat i would rather netherrealm
just
make the license monster movie fighting
game they so clearly want to make
yeah
like just go all in right
they really really should
but i get that it's probably easier to
like sell it is like dlc for moral
combat
i'm sure that's the better business
strategy but like come on
range damage for teammates
uh we got multiple i should pick someone
else
uh then we already got i'll go support
again he'll go support
should i go
i'll go hunter
i'm the guy with the gun
see when activated uh your dodge without
any stamina and your ranged attacks
uh cause bleeding damage to your target
for a short period
interesting okay so go get a ranged
weapon
i like that like
pre like seeing [ __ ] ash his whole thing
is just making everyone calmer
yeah
before he went crazy
uh s wants to know is the hand really an
enemy in this game oh that's a good
question they show it on the loading
screen
so you you can you can booby trap it in
one of the boxes
so that when when people go to open up
like the loot boxes they find in houses
it'll jump out and like like latch onto
them that's cool
oh here we go yeah we're fighting these
guys excellent
i can never make amends for the i do
wish
i mean i guess i don't know i don't know
what all the maps are but i do wish
there was a map that was just straight
up like construction the medieval times
uh
yeah see like
that kind of stuff that's that's what
i'm talking like post game of like they
can address launch
pages
okay
give me the loot we already know where
one of the pieces are
you love to see it so let's quickly get
some
stuff and then let's uh
i also like that the uh like there is a
loot phase but it's like looting is
hardly a thing yeah looting isn't really
a thing i mean you definitely want to
try and find like good [ __ ] but um
it's not quite
it's more just like oh you know
you want to keep going right and and yes
if you find good loot on the way
like i obviously don't want to hold on
to this meat cleaver for as long as i
i mean maybe i got a meat cleaver but
it's a purple meat cleaver so it's
pretty good oh shoot
oh no
i'm uh i'm marking a chainsaw for one of
you guys
unfortunately i won't be able to use it
one of the other ashes will
uh
okay
yeah that's it for me all right
uh santa in the chat says the chainsaw
mk was leather face they're right it was
leather face wasn't it
uh in an mk-10
oh yeah
there's a teaser
at the end of like with a character like
the season one pass trailer for 11. i
remember where there was a chainsaw rav
and the huge thing was that it was
supposed to be ash
right yeah i remember that but yeah i
know you're right leatherface was 10
wasn't it
because cause
11. that was the time where they were
like let's put all the monsters in the
game for real this time yeah they did um
predator and they did alien in that one
uh a good shout though
and then 11 was more like we got
rambo and salone uh stallone they're not
stolen stella is rambo
for the arnold schwarzenegger but not
arnold schwarzenegger
here let's uh let's mark this this hut
and this all did they put like old sarah
connor in a game wasn't she in something
as well i think she was a skin for like
sonia blade or something
interesting
uh do you want to get in this car
i do but it looks like we're all afraid
to drive so i'm going to do it
no one wants to be the person to drive
this guy getting in come on in bud uh
let's see um has there been any word if
this will come to steam in the future uh
i am not sure actually
usually i haven't seen or heard anything
but yeah usually deals like this it's
like uh oh it'll come in like a year
kind of thing which
ah if that's the case i don't know like
uh hard to say
um
how much this game will be active in a
year i mean you know i hope it does well
but
who knows
um where's the review the game just came
out so uh our reviewers gotta you know
test the multiplayer play a bunch of
online matches in a live environment so
i would say don't expect anything until
at least early next week
um
hacky sacked was said old sarah connor
was in gears 5. that is correct it was
gears that what a weird one
yeah right gears has a weird history
with uh
guest characters too oh they're
possessing the car what they could do
that oh yes so you can possess the car
and drive to people my god
i love that
oh that's so cool man i was like there's
no reason for us to get kicked out and
then all of a sudden i'm like oh wait a
minute being yeah being the demon seems
pretty fun
oh i think it's over here yeah yeah yeah
all right
got that piece
you're nice
hidden piece of the map
keep moving and find another
all right i keep forgetting i need to
like level up my character
a railway loot
which is just north of us
oh easy we could just walk there
yeah
i've i've marked it
uh graphics look decent on real engine
i'm not sure what engine this is on
do you remember it does look nice though
and the too much sharp screens this game
displays
yeah when you start it up it makes sure
you know everyone who's involved
uh
[Music]
but i don't remember what engine that's
running on
also i like this map is not uh at night
yeah i like when you get like a little
bit of uh
some light going on
uh also just because i heard the line
when the execution happened uh i liked
the evil dead was set in michigan
because that's where i was from
so that was a fun thing growing up
uh just be like ah yes i've been to that
forest where that cabin is
did they film it in michigan
i don't know if it actually was i just
know that they like they have michigan
license plates and they talk about
michigan
uh also
uh
your character keeps talking about how
they're they're born born in michigan
every time they're murdering someone
yeah well then my character is from the
tv show so maybe the tv show uh they
shot in michigan or takes place thank
you
your team now holds another a
blunderbuss
keep it close and continue
oh someone's bleeding out
shoot
don't do that uh we should go
i'm gonna go run to them
oh he's playing a flute ah i'm just
scared dang it
yeah i'm gonna come help
the dude jesus sit there playing the
play in the flute
uh jonathan evans says the original
cabin was in uh
nc i believe that's north carolina right
what was it
the characters must have been the evil
dead was set and filmed in the nc uh tn
border so north carolina tennessee
border
say they had the license plates i
thought at least but that that could be
wrong maybe think of something else
but your character is very she's
mentioned michigan like seven times okay
then that's definitely the tv show is
very michigan centric
i'm gonna pick this
does this game include every evil dead
including army of darkness and the
netflix evil dead uh yeah it includes um
the
all the original movies army of darkness
i mean this dude right here is
one of the night guys from army of
darkness we're actually fighting the
army of darkness skeletons on this map
which is cool as heck
uh and then yeah uh my character is from
uh ash uh versus uh the evil dead tv
show so yeah they everything seems to be
represented with the exception of the
evil dead yo there's the guys by the way
yeah they're over there we gotta go
south to get the last map piece all
right is that what you are doing yeah
yeah nice um the only thing they don't
soon i represented is the
the reboot or
not reboot reboot's not the right word i
guess like the redo the remake remake
reimagining um the evil dead
that movie that came out in like
2014 or whatever it was
the only one that's not represented
which i i guess is fair because it's a
different timeline it's not the same
thing um but as i mentioned before i
actually do quite like that movie
yeah
i'd see it as like a uh
maybe maybe like a dlc pack if they
wanted
they they just need to have a part in
this game where it rains blood
i i feel like anything's a possibility
got him
nice
i feel like shooting a skeleton might be
one of the hardest things you could try
to do
i haven't seen evil dead 2014 it's good
it's a very different movie like i i you
really have to go in uh
not like don't compare it to
evil dead because it's it's very much
trying to do a different thing um
it's trying to be like a little more
like gory and shocking in that way
spirit's there though the spirit's there
and then like i said the last 30 minutes
just goes like off the rails in a really
fun way that i super enjoyed
yeah
yeah
yo your boy has got some bad luck but i
found the piece of math nice
with the final piece of the map in your
possession only the demon stands between
it would make sense that the the game
where i was like man you don't need to
worry about loot too much i'd get like
the worst loot
so i've still got like a gray machete
and a gray hunting rifle yeah i do have
a gray pistol but i at least have this
this solid hammer but um my character is
ranged focused and i haven't found a
ranged weapon yet outside of my pistol
so not great
not ideal
uh okay we should probably head to the
uh
the page right
and the deck yeah we got a
car here
i'm gonna get some more coal uh
just make sure to mark the book since
it's a little bit closer
who's who's down why are they down
what what is this what is this ash doing
all the time
yeah what the heck
what are they doing are they
like role-playing something
okay
who's campbell voice act in this game he
do multiple times he does
pretty all right pretty solid
ah someone in the chat says uh they did
a quick google search and it looks like
they changed the setting to michigan for
the ash versus evil dead show so
there you go they like retroactively
said uh this takes place in michigan
uh the license plate on that car says
michigan
that's great
they're doing it look at that
great lakes
them good old great lakes
all right let's be honest
uh they've got this the spookiest bridge
i've ever been on
uh in michigan
like imagine the
like
the golden gate bridge but you can see
through the whole thing because it's
made out of metal
like see-through grated metal
get in here dude
get in loser
we're looking for the necronomicon
there it is
[Music]
this went horribly
it's not too far away
i'm gonna light this though
you guys losing your minds back there
all right we got him we got him
there we go
oh thank you everyone
look out calm down
oh let's find a new card
steal yourself
come on on the pages let's go
oh that's uh that's her man that's her
dude yeah that's the dude
he's evil he's ash he's here
he's angry oh he got me
i don't know if a friends realize it
oh they're getting you back up that's
good
my body
you okay
i'm i'm getting there
did we get him no no not yet oh
oh the flute get the flute
fail from the first day
how about that
i'm having a good time
yeah
i mean i'm gonna try to get our friend
back up really fast there haven't been
much uh like server issues or anything
that's always the big thing with uh
games like this and they're so
multiplayer
dependent
yeah it's it's been running pretty
smooth
game doesn't have too many like
like problems running uh
cross play seems to work great it's easy
to get into matches because of cross
play too which is always a plus
okay big guy's almost down yeah there we
go
and the page is almost done
which means
we should get some cool loot here in a
bit and maybe that'll make it easier for
us
the living are one step closer
uh someone's got a boom stick
it's a boom
stick all right i'm also gonna
arranged up my health there we go
is he gonna is he gonna take that am i
gonna take it
i'm taking it
someone's gotta take it
all right there's something you should
see all right i'm gonna start opening
the dagger
mark that so it's easier to see just in
case
see everyone's yelling because they're
they're losing their sanity
ash quebec i can help you my name's ash
is the name captain picard a pun for
john luke's name yes uh my
name is captain picard because uh
my name is
it's a it's a it's a good it's a good
thing
oh another blue box over here purple one
oh chainsaw chainsaw
can get that for that guy someone come
sell and take that purple chainsaw
excuse you better
why is he
come on man
hilarious
oh and i got jump scared too dang it
dude we're not at the tagger yet
who is bbc edits
uh just a random player that uh we're
with
our friend and yours
here to help us survive
oh thank god a new melee weapon
nice
all right
i'm not gonna i'm
scrambling trying to find loot in
between things
i hear here i'm using that chainsaw so
that's good uh i got a bunch of skeleton
boys on my ass right here
coming to you
oh
uh evil ash
he's there on youtube yeah he's there on
me i'm gonna definitely die
because he is
don't do it
all right i'm collecting the dagger i
have no way to heal the group has begun
to collect
initiating a period of battle against
the dead
remain close to ensuring
i mean this game will fail not you sir
oh no that's why i know you're referring
to but um i don't know it's hard to say
i prefer to be optimistic about games
uh yeah
i i want all games to succeed
because really like when a game doesn't
succeed people are sad and that's no
good yeah the game game does succeed
people are happy
also i i i'm not of the opinion that
like every game needs to be this like
amazing success to
like
succeed or like to be considered a
failure like hey as long as the game
does well enough and finds an audience
and is able to like you know
be
do well and the developers kind of get
their money back and i consider that a
success personally
i don't want to die
did we get a evil ash
i have no idea he's i don't see him so i
think he's gone
how similar is this to fry the 13th it's
actually quite different uh because
you are um
not trying to hide it's way more combat
focused
and then um
uh instead of a big guy
playing um
sort of like one person uh like
you know a jason
um
you are the
demon person kind of is like i don't
know they're not like exactly
controlling all the skeletons but they
do have like the ability to kind of
manipulate yeah they're dropping them in
and they're able to control one at a
time
yeah
kind of uh i don't know sort of like a
little bit of
i want to say like a fusion of left 4
dead car possessed car
not again got me the car got me dude the
car was brutal
but yeah i would say it's it's kind of
like this interesting fusion between um
like friday the 13th and like left for
dead almost in some ways if that makes
sense that's not like a perfect
comparison but if if you were to like
try and like compare two games yo pick
ax
somehow it's not not as good as my melee
weapon that i've got it's a little
better than mine so i'm gonna take it
then
all right man we just gotta go kill
those dudes right
yeah uh
i
have a bunch of wish i had health
uh definitely make sure to upgrade
yourself if you haven't in a hot minute
i'm gonna go look inside this house for
something to heal myself with yeah
that's a good call
it seems that we don't have a time limit
to take them out which is nice
yeah
oh heck yeah that's what i'm talking
about
what you find uh
found something to heal
nice
i got some shields going that's good
get out of here skeletons
go run over to be with you guys what is
the general consensus on this game good
question i'm actually not sure i haven't
really been looking at
the overall thoughts of people but
so far i'm having a solid time
yeah i'm i'm enjoying it
nope we got evil last year again
and then he's absolutely gonna kill me
no
yep he got me
damn i got on quick
here i'm gonna try to
the sneaky revive here
oh thank you
yeah you got me you got me just barely
hell yeah oh he might get me uh he
immediately got me wow
well now he's upset at me
yeah he's like how dare you
you're just gonna camp them like that i
got friends behind you
i'm gonna say it evil evil ash seems
like a jerk
almost dead get him get him yeah we all
got him oh thank god
fear's high i'm gonna bring it down real
quick
oh i got spooked again
okay
i'm half health now that's okayish
uh
we should probably head and get rid of
those guys right yeah i think we're
probably overdue for that
okay
they are this way
i'm just kind of hoping we find
do we have a healer
uh it's me but it's not direct healing
which is that's unfortunate because
apparently they heal by or this ash
heals by meleeing
enemies
oh cause i'm actually gonna die
again uh so what's the main objective
the
main objective is you're supposed to
collect uh three pages of a map that map
tells you where the page to the
necronomicon of the dagger are you have
to go collect those
uh we have to then fight these big dudes
over here uh that you can see i'm down
by the way um
and then after that uh we have to then
collect the necronomicon if we do all
that we win
oh i die died yeah shoot
bomber
i believe in you guys
oh he's carrying your soul though oh
okay
you bring it back do it man if you can
we'll see let's see if he brings me back
that'd be cool
oh my gosh
is the jank off-putting can you see
yourself playing this long term uh
honestly like
i i don't find it that janky if i'm
being yeah it's surprisingly
well put together
in my opinion i got totally revived heck
yeah
love it
i've knocked off one of their health
things
saw gun this is pretty cool actually
i'm gonna run to this house really quick
and look for healing things all right
i'm gonna try and take one of their
health my little ghostbuster attack
um the other part of that question was
can you see yourself playing this long
term hard to say i mean i definitely
like oh we got evil ash
this guy
sucks
i'm tired of this guy oh
all right i'm gonna try to get a revive
on never mind
oh he said no
dude i gotta be honest evil ash seems
kind of busted
he does
uh
i also i know at least i wasn't uh
leveled up very high
i don't know how that would stick up
because they're they're like a 29 threat
man
probably not gonna make it then
but yeah as far as whether i'm going to
play this game long term
i don't really know i mean i don't to be
like it's a game i'd leave installed and
it like this isn't a game i like i'd
start up every day after i get done with
everything it's like a hey do you guys
want to play
the evil dead game and then we would
play it
exactly um i mean that's kind of how i
treat games like dead by daylight is
just be like oh hey y'all want to play
something by daylight sure i don't like
playing that game like every day or
anything the way some people do it's not
my like my game of choice
i guess is it something i'm going to
keep on my my hard drive so i'll have it
whenever i want to play it i'd say yeah
yeah probably
all right
let's go again
i did yeah
up though i think so actually let me see
if i can
put points into anything
or no uh oh yeah i did level up her cool
cool cool
i have also leveled up
let's see uh increased range weapon
damage reduce the amount of fear
received from any source increase your
maximum stamina
probably ranged weapon damage
okay
cool
sick sick sick
back at it
play as
survivor i do not like that i have to
reinvite you every time
yeah it is weird that you can't just
stay in a party
that is kind of annoying
uh invite
also this invite system at least on uh
pc is a little
like the menu system is kind of
cumbersome
yeah
hey it works i guess hey it works we are
able to do it at least
in the games they come so quick
yeah they load fast it's nice
i do like having a game where day one i
can just play it
it's nice it is silly how we got to take
it well look at that look at that bruce
got it
a fresh fresh show look
oh that's uh that's uh they must have
done them the mission to unlock old
bruce campbell i know someone said i
love that
okay so who do we got here uh we got got
a support
i don't know what ash williams
uh from evil from from versus i don't
know what class he is
yeah i don't either but we got cheryl's
support
or no they switched yeah okay their
support annie's
i guess i'll go hunter
go for it may i'll do a warrior type of
thing
should i go hunter shake a warrior
uh whichever you want i'll go the
opposite
i'll go support again you know what i'll
stick i'll stick with uh kelly
you gotta take that army of darkness ash
with me wherever i go
doesn't because it looks so slow and oh
and if it doesn't look like something
you'd enjoy then there isn't much you
can do to kind of like yeah exactly
right don't change it
i'm not certain that this is cool it's
so cold
oh you know this is one of the
we've been on this map but now it's just
snowing all right
oh so we got weather conditions
uh the my textures are freaking out
though on the ground
i don't know if they're doing that for
you
uh i'm i'm all right right now
yeah that's not great i do like the
multiple
weather time of day stuff that is nice
it helps add some good variety
yeah cause i was definitely concerned
about like oh okay like are the maps
gonna kind of get a little tiring and
that might still be the case who knows
i can kill with this
if i can lift it this is us all figuring
it out as uh as we're playing
you guys have seen our
reactions alive
if you want to there's i marked the
thing i opened up
it had like three three level up things
in it oh thank you yes i will definitely
come grab that
wish you could jump
yeah missing a jump button is a thing
i
don't know why they didn't do that
nope hold on i gotta get rid of a
spammer in the chat
get out of here
so the first one is in the the witch
village which is oh that's actually
i'll mark it just
so we we have a point of reference
oh this is a fun little cave area
[Music]
spooky mind
is this better than the evil dead game
for dreamcast i've actually never played
the dreamcast evil dead game
oh there's the one with the fixed camera
angles i think hail to the king is not
the good one
uh there's another one that was much
better is the fixed camera angle the
heels of the king or is that the other i
think i think halo the king is the fixed
camera angle one okay was it trying to
be like a resident evil thing or
i don't
maybe i just remember the combat being
not great
but the other there was another one with
like it's like open world and like ran
around and
you play pretty well that's cool
i think i played it on xboxes where i
remember i don't know if that's the
dreamcast one we're talking about but
right hey the next one is where we're at
tank you'd love to see it wow
this this is the game
everything's coming up us
boy still doesn't have a ranged weapon
and i would like to change that yeah i
don't either i'm definitely lacking for
good stuff um
i'm also not finding this map piece
got this pickaxe though and that's doing
me pretty well i found them out found it
nice yeah
okay
we're gonna head over to the circus
cages surely
first time uh also hold on
freya head out uh more level up stuff
over here
oh and more in here too i'm finding a
whole bunch of things to open nice
and a
shovel here take i think i pick axe two
by the way yeah yeah definitely
yeah i'm i'm more about that than shovel
life yeah if you find like a ranged
weapon that's kind of my my character's
whole deal
will do
okay
a little bit arranged stamina
nice you want to talk about swissful
boomstick there it is that was that was
one
uh i like that one
uh looking forward to more hangouts bye
hey thank you uh
thanks for tuning in man appreciate it
we we love doing these streams when we
can they're fun
here we go hunting rifle let's go
uh where are we going next misery manor
that's a misery manner
uh
i'm gonna mark that one
my orange one you know it's good
stick
it's pretty far though
so
maybe we should take this get a card
yeah i'm coming to you there's one right
over here
yeah thanks everyone who's been uh
tuning in uh hanging out on the stream
this friday appreciate it hopefully you
all are having a
fun time and uh
hope you all have a good friday and a
good weekend it's real
it may maybe
maybe run into you playing evil dead
yeah
see should we try and pick up this
person
me as well
oh unless they're trying to figure out
them
i know these zombies are also just not
moving
they're just thinking you know
whoa disappeared
there we go
props on gaming and being responsive see
this is the secret we have two of us so
we can like
move around like sean luke is driving
right now oh the car possessed it uh was
driving was driving not anymore and i
was able to talk
it's it's it's stuff like that
but we
we try yeah i'm definitely bad at it on
my own for sure it's a
it's a skill it's it is a skill
a tough one at that all right that
person just said i'm going on my own
hey it's cool now the card's not
possessed you can
get in if you want
look no no it's still possessed stay
away
you you gonna come in i can't tell if
they're coming in or not also i don't
know one of them
it's them
oh are they possessed uh they're
possessed
oh should we should we get them
yeah we probably should break them out
of it i think okay
no no they don't look possessed they
seem fine
oh
never mind all right
they don't want to get in the car let's
just go
yeah
uh dig in this snowstorm though
yeah the weather whether there's a thing
that gets overlooked i think
oh yeah
it's a it's a cool little feature
also i appreciate
the flexibility of this car to navigate
tight spaces
all right we're here
nailed it
we got some more level up stuff i've got
i need i need to spend points i have
nine that i'm sitting on
i've been picking them up but i keep
forgetting to spend them crossbow
oh crossbow the hunting rifle i mean it
does more damage but it's way slower
rate i'm gonna stick with the rifle
i think
just realize this crossbow you love to
see it for a game like this dude
absolutely it really is like
i i think that just gives this game way
a way better shot of uh
you know oh do you still need a weapon
by the way um i'm always looking for a
better weapon i found a saw gun that's
blue
oh yeah i should go with that honestly
nice i saw that that was good
i like that i like that a lot
okay uh
just looking for that map piece
is there another building here maybe
it's like i feel like we would have seen
the map if it were
it well it kind of pops up right when
you get closer to it
yeah it's also it's also pretty big
yeah now we already checked the basement
here
no
this can't be just the misery that the
misery manner has to be more
oh i think misery manor is the whole
area in the light gray
that's probably in one of these other
buildings aha found it oh okay that's
good to know
the final piece has been here making the
map whole again i'm about to find out
oh yeah you know what i will be good
if i see any more though i'll let you
know
actually i will use this opportunity to
up my
shield
hey
anything upstairs
i just found like an amulet like a
hunting rifle yeah that's good
okay
maybe as we'll check the other house out
across the street though oh sure
and then we should join them because i
think they're they're moving on it
yeah i think they're moving on that
stuff
a couple people popping in asking how
the game is pretty alright so far we're
having a fun time
yeah it's it's it's fun
uh i'm giggling at all the the silly
references
it's uh
definitely it's a good time yeah yeah if
you're an evil dead fan
it's a good time oh no no no why can't i
not move
oh i see i see you moving yeah i see you
standing there you get disconnected
i
no i can still mark things
interesting
hello
we were just talking about how we've had
a mostly smooth experience i was gonna
say i've jinxed it
don't she cannot say that again
what did she say she said we're keeping
michigan moist ew
i don't know why
i don't know what i'm gonna plug in a
controller and see what happens i don't
know
cause like i'm i'm still in the game
yeah you're not like dc8 or anything
you're able to mark that ammo
hello
i'll i'll guard you for a sec while you
will you try and start that out
wait i i don't just move the camera
i don't know what is
what is this
your group has roused the lost pages of
the necronomicon transmitting a psychic
wave to all corrupted souls
hold your ground buttons are still
still there why why can't i not move am
i i'm not like stuck on any geometry i'm
in the middle of the room yeah you're
fine
shoot you might have to go on without me
oh no
it's okay i'll i'll break free on my own
time all right and then i'll i'll join
up with you guys later they probably
need your help so
i'm gonna i'm gonna go
find them
it's a glitch maybe that's the first
time we've encountered any anything like
that
yeah
oh
did you get out i'm
bit
nice i'm invincible
all right uh i'm heading over to the
page
i'm on my way nice
so if you ever get stuck this is for
everyone who's here this is
exclusive uh use your ulta ability
it'll set you free okay okay good to
know uh because i was like what do i
have that changes animation i can switch
on and off my flashlight
uh and then i was like ah
using the thing it made me move smart
smart thinking
you just smart uh
just something about shotguns
hoops
nice
i keep forgetting that there is a heavy
attack
oh i got jump scared i don't like it
completely forgot there was two you're
right
i haven't found it i don't know i feel
like i don't need it but maybe i'm on
yeah i tend to use like
heavier weapons so it's usually just
like a a one hit and then a finish for
me
or are you already moving on the next
thing well if you want some upgrades
there were a couple over here oh shoot
you're right i do i want that
why did i follow why did i follow them
uh i just got a loading screen no
i got booted online service unavailable
that's not it oh man
uh can you join in progress
let's find out because
dang
i was like doing good too probably gonna
get some good points man
making me a liar game i was talking
about how i haven't had any issues
we jinxed it full on we did we full on
jinxed it uh
i don't know if there's a way to
see if i can like go into a social menu
or something yeah let me see if i can um
pull up and like join your game
i feel bad that i might have to abandon
these people but i might have to abandon
these people i mean
it's okay we're probably going to want
to end here anyway um
right before because i actually have
some i have a i have an important work
meeting
this might actually be the right spot it
doesn't look like i can rejoin which is
a bummer um
so i think we're going to call it here
then uh yeah dude that was evil dead the
game
so far
kind of ended on a on a bit of a
a bummer note getting booted but i'll
say i'm enjoying what i play what i've
played in this game so far i think it's
pretty
pretty neat
and uh yeah i want to check out more i
haven't checked out any of these like
single player missions
um i love this menu where they all look
like cassette tapes
yeah it's cool like there's some good
some good vibes in this game
uh
yeah i don't know i just want to play
more of this this game seems neat and uh
if you want to check it out uh it's on
xbox it's on playstation and it's on the
epic game store which
i wish it was on steam but
and what are you gonna do
so uh yeah thanks for watching everybody
and hope you have a
lovely friday all you wonderful
wonderful people
you